I'm an immigrant from Venezuela and I've
lived in the US for six years if you ask
me about my life as an expatriate I
would say that I've been lucky but it
hasn't been easy growing up I never
thought that I was going to leave my
homeland I participated in my first
student protest in 2007 when the
president shut down one of the most
important news networks I was getting my
bachelor's degree in communications and
that was the first time I'd realized I
couldn't take free speech for granted we
knew things were getting bad but we
never saw what was coming and economic
crisis infrastructure breaking down cdy
electrical blackouts the decline of
public health care and shortage of
medicines
this is outbreaks and salvation I moved
to Canada with my husband in 2013 and we
always thought we moved back home when
the crisis improved but he never did
nearly all my childhood friends have
left the country but my parents are
still there there have been moments
where I'd call my mom and I could hear
people screaming and crying in the
background still gas bombs exploded in
the streets and my mom as if I as if I
couldn't hear it would always tell me
not a preoccupation either I'm huyang
we're fine don't worry but of course
that I worry it's my parents and I'm
4,000 months away today I'm just one of
more than 4 million Venezuelans who've
left their home country a lot of our
friends are Venezuelan immigrants and in
the last few years we began talking
about how we could make a difference
when we leave so far away that it's held
call for Venezuela was born in 2019 it
began with a hackathon because we are
all experts in tech and we thought we
could use our tacit skills to create
solutions for people on the ground
but first we needed to find some experts
actually living inside Venezuela to
guide us we'd see so many other
hackathons came up with wildly ambitious
incredible technological solutions that
sound great in theory but ultimately
failed to work in the actual countries
they were intended to help many of us
have been living abroad for years and we
are detached from the day-to-day
problems that people are facing in
Venezuela so we turned to the experts
actually living inside the countries for
example julio castro a doctor and one of
the leaders of america for la salud when
the government stopped publishing
official health care data in 2015 the
peculiar began in collecting information
himself using an informal but
coordinated system of cell phone
communications
they track available personnel medical
supplies mortality data disease
outbreaks compiled it into a report and
then shared on Twitter he became our
go-to expert on health care in Venezuela
Luis Carlos Diaz a widely recognized
journalist who reports acts of
censorship and human rights violations
suffered by the people of Venezuela he
helps us make sense of what is happening
there since the news is controlled by
the government because these people are
heroes on the ground with the expert
advice we came up with a series of
challenges for hackathon participants in
that first hackathon we had 300
participants from 7 countries come up
with 16 different projects two missions
we pick the projects with most potential
and continue working on them after the
event today I'll share two of our most
successful projects to give you a taste
of the impact we are having so far
they're called
MIDI tweets and blackout tracker Mary
tweets is an intelligent Twitter part
that helps Venezuelans find the medicine
they need right now
in Venezuela if you get sick and you go
to hospital there is a good chance they
won't have the right medical supplies to
train
the situation is so bad that patients
often get a shopping list from the
doctor instead of a prescription I live
the need for this firsthand my mom was
diagnosed with cancer in 2015 she needed
to have a lumbar puncture to get a final
diagnosis and treatment plan but the
needle for this procedure wasn't
available I was in Venezuela at that
time and I was seeing my mom getting
worse in front of me every day after
looking everywhere
we found the needle in a site that is
like the eBay of Latin America
I met the seller in a local bakery and
he was like buying something on the
black market my mom brought the needle
to her doctor and he did the procedure
without this she could have died but
it's not just medical supplies it's many
things too when she was first announced
we bought her treatment in a state
pharmacy and it was like practically
free but then the state pharmacy ran out
and we still had six months of trevenant
ahead six months of treatment ahead we
want some medicines online and then read
the rest in Mexico now she's in her
third year of remission and every time
that I call she tells me I'm fine don't
worry but not everyone can afford to
leave the country and many are in
healthy enough to travel but it's why
people turn to Twitter buying and
selling medicines using the hashtag
servicio público meaning public service
our Twitter body scans Twitter for the
hashtag servicio público and connects
users were asking for specific medicines
widows who are selling their private
left overs we also pull the location
data of those twitter users and use it
for a visualization tool it gives local
organizations like Maricopa life salud a
sense of where they have a shortage we
can also apply machine learning
algorithms to detect clusters of disease
if they receive humanitarian aid this
could help them to make better decisions
about the
distributions of the supplies our second
project it's called blackout tracker
Venezuela it's currently - through an
electricity crisis last year when as
well as suffered what some people
consider the worst powers failures in
Venezuela history I had two long days
without communication with my parents
some cities experienced blackouts every
day but you only know about these on
social media the government won't report
blackouts on the news when the power
goes out
many Venezuelans we quickly tweet out
the location with the hashtag seen loose
meaning without electricity before their
phones ran out of battery so people
around the country know what it's
happening like mary tweet blackout
tracker scans twitter for the hashtag
seen loose and creates a map using the
location data of those users you can
quickly see where the blackouts are
happening today and how many deaths have
happened over time people want to know
what it's happening and this is our
answer but it's also a way of holding
the government accountable it's easy for
them to deny that the praluent sees or
make excuses because there is no
official data on it
blackout tracker shows how bad the
problem release now some people in
Silicon Valley may look at these
projects and say that there are no major
technological innovations pretends the
point these projects are not insanely
advanced but is what the people of
Venezuela need and they can have a
tremendous impact beyond these projects
perhaps our most significant
accomplishment is that a movement has
been created one where people around the
world are coming together to use their
professional skills to create solutions
for people of Venezuela and because we
are partnering with locals we are
creating the solutions that people want
and need what is so great about these is
that we are using our professional
skills so it comes easily and naturally
it's not that hard for us to make a beef
friends if someone from San Francisco
we're to hire professionals to create
solutions like Mary tweets or blackout
tracker it would cost a small fortune by
donating our services we are making a
bigger impact if we were just to the
name money and you can do the same thing
not in Venezuela necessarily but in your
own community in a world that is more
connected than ever we'd still see how
specialized communities can be living in
isolated or in silos there are so many
great ways to help but I believe that
you can use your professional skills to
connect diverse communities and create
effective solutions through those
relationships anyone with knowledge and
professional skills has a powerful force
to bring hope to a community for us at
ecole for Venezuela this is just the
beginning thank you
[Applause]